So a distributed loss level cache
is logically a single cache in that
a data block will not be replicated
like it would be in private caches,
where if two or three or four cores, for
example, read a block, each of
their caches would have that block.
And thus,
really the total capacity of the caches
is not how much memory we are covering,
because some memory appears many times,
possibly in these caches.
A last level cache that is distributed
is logically still one cache,
meaning if it's capacity is
let's say four megabytes,
then we really cover four megabytes
of memory without any replication.
But this distributed cache is sliced
up so that each tile, which contains
a core and possibly local caches,
now also contains a part of this cache.
So now what we have is in our mash,
we have a tile that contains a core,
a level one cache, a level two cache,
and a slice of the L3 cache.
So if this slice here that we
use per core is let's say 1MB,
is really N x 1MB where N
is the number of cores, so
now as you can see,
if we use four cores,
we get 4MB, with 16 cores we have 16MB,
so we get what we want.
The big cache that is there
to prevent memory accesses
is growing with the number of cores, but
it doesn't have a single entry point.
In fact,
each slice has its own entry point.
So if we want the data
that is in this slice,
we have to route our
message to that slice.
If we want the data that
resides in another slice,
we send the message there.
If the data is spread among
the slices so that all
of them get equal demands for the data,
then the natural traffic will be nicely
distributed across our chip, so that
none of the links get over utilized.
But if we have a level two
miss in a particular core,
how do we know which slice of the level
three cache to ask for the data?
One simple solution is
to spread the cache,
a round robin among slices,
by cache index.
So if we have our level
three cache with let's say,
1,024 sets slice zero gets set zero.
Slice one gets set one, etc., and
then let's say that we have eight cores.
Then slice seven gets set seven.
Slice zero gets set eight.
Set nine is in slice one again and
so on.
So now we can relatively easily,
after we break down the address to
access the cache,
we know the set number, and
the least significant tree bits in
this case tell us which slice to ask.
If we have even more cores, then the
number of sets in the cache will grow,
and as a result the number of bits
that we need to tell us which slice we
have is growing and that means that the
number of bits in the index are growing,
and we will need additional bits
to tell us in which set to look.
Know that if we sequentially access
data, then we would be really be looking
at one set and then the next and
then the next set, and
this nicely spreads the load among
the slices of the level three cache.
Because sequential axises
are basically going to be spread
across the entire shape.
However, the spreading of blocks
round robin across the entire chip
may not be good for locality,
because a core is just as likely to
access something that is in the opposite
corner of the chip, as it is to access
its own slice in which case there is
no on chip network traffic whatsoever.
So another way that can help with that
is that we spread the data around, but
this time we spread it by page number.
So all of the blocks that belong to the
same page would end up in the same slice
of the level three, that helps because
now the operating system can map pages,
so that it makes the accesses
to L3 more local.
For example here, this core is
running a thread that has a stack.
The pages that belong to that stack
should be those that end up in
this slice.
So that if you have a level two miss,
we are very likely to access our
own local slice of the L3 cache.
Of course, some of the shared
data will be elsewhere, but
this dramatically improves the locality
in terms of how far do we need to go
to get to the correct slice of L3.
Any data that tends to
be accessed by one core
can be now mapped by
the operating system so
that it's usually found in the local
slice of the last level cache.